all right so what is the most nutrient
dense food
on the planet not plants
organ meats organ meats
have 10 to 100 times more concentrated
nutrients
than muscle meat you know like if you're
going to get a chicken breast or a steak
or a hamburger
it has more bioavailable iron zinc
selenium vitamin a vitamin d b12
magnesium b1 b2 alpha lipoic acid b6
phosphorus choline coenzyme q10
well certain types of organ meats like
the heart tissue for example
and k2 okay
now here's the problem with plants
there's no b12
there's no d3 there's no dha which
is an omega-3 fatty acid you get the
precursor which is ala
but you only convert a certain amount
the other problem with plants is that
the vitamin a
is in the form of a pre-vitamin a and if
you're going to compare vitamin a
it's really like 20 times less of course
they don't really
tell you about that they just say
vitamin a but it's in the form
of beta-carotene the other problem with
plants is they have phytates which are
anti-nutrients so they block
certain minerals like iron
calcium magnesium zinc
so even though certain vegetables might
have more magnesium for example
the question is are they available to
you
now the reason why i recommend plants
for magnesium
and potassium because it's much easier
to get that nutrient
because you would have to consume i
don't know 700 grams
of animal meats to get the same
magnesium for example as you would seven
cups
of vegetables so plants definitely are
good for certain things and this is of
course
why you'd want to combine eating plants
with the animal products unless you have
very severe
gut issues so now the question is what
do plants have
that organ meats don't have well
they are loaded with something called
phytonutrients and phytonutrients have
some seriously amazing effects
for your health anti-inflammatory
anti-cancer
anti-diabetic anti-microbial antiviral
the list goes on and on and on so
phytonutrients give us
a lot of benefit with our health
plants have more vitamin k1
and i've already mentioned the potassium
and the magnesium so you would want to
combine them
but realize that organ meats out of
all the foods have the most concentrated
nutrients
in the most bioavailable source so
personally
even though i know that i don't like to
consume
organ meats i just don't like the taste
so sometimes i'll get them in
supplements or i'll get them hidden
in hamburger for example u.s wellness
meats
has various products various types of
hamburger that
they blended in certain organ meats and
the one that i really like
which i'll put a link down below and by
the way i don't get any kickbacks or
anything like that
is the one with hamburger with a little
bit of heart meat which is
loaded with coenzyme q10 and i will say
when i consume that
i do feel i have more endurance so you
might want to check that out
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course
will show you how to bulletproof
yourself and so you can tolerate and
resist
your environment much better by
strengthening
your own immune system i put a link down
in the description right down below
check it out and get signed up today